to me the sixers are a five seed tops
i think they're going to conference
finals buying them
obvious monster i have three point
shooting don't eat
i bit my lip at lunch today
sucks anyway i just don't see it the
knicks
are tough the nets are tough oh the nets
are super tough
now i have this big bump in my lip that
hurts
i hate it the hawks
are terrible they're always terrible
okay you need to think about it before
you come with the
whatever it's not a big deal you know i
always tell my three-year-old if this is
the worst thing that's gonna happen
you gotta be kidding me okay pam
that's it i'm going home
if people are afraid to walk by diaz
bathroom breaks will be to a minimum
hey diaz i just need to make sure i've
got the details right in this file
yeah guy was passing bad checks but is
this the same guy
yeah the name here is the same name okay
all right thank you thank you got it
come on i'm so sick of these sucky
computers
one more step in your next
did you forget something what happened
to you guys
give it back
the gift basket give it back what is
this it's real simple
if you don't appreciate what we do then
give us back our basket
maybe you should leave yeah maybe we
should
maybe you should leave come on let's
leave but before we leave
my wet friend and i are gonna wait for
our cabs on your
nice couches can you call us a cab
please i'm gonna oh
sorry look my clothes are so wet wet
nice leather
oh my shoes are so muddy all right here
you go take it there
it's been opened yeah it was mine what's
missing
for turtles where are the turtles where
are the turtles come on guys get out of
here where
are the turtles where
are they all right listen
the case may not be quite as urgent as
once thought um
[Music]
i dug it up out of my desk so you'd have
something to do on weekends because you
seem so lonely
you cited chatter from the streets that
garibaldi had resurfaced
i did i did i did but said chatter may
have been fudged
so you lied to me i had a pity you
pitied me
i wouldn't put it that way i would i am
offended i am angry
i am very tired so i'm gonna take a nap
but when i wake up
ugh you are in for it
how dare you i have two relationships
with anthony
i have a personal relationship and i
have a professional relationship
personally yeah i think he's a rat and i
think he's responsible for the demise of
my
relationship with aaron professionally
he broke up the happiest couple in this
office how many windows are there in new
york city
what critical thinking common
on-the-spot question asked in an
interview
okay uh let me think are you counting
car windows no how far away is the sun
uh 93 million miles does it
yeah and the diameter of the sun is 870
thousand miles which makes it 109 times
wider than the earth
and 333 000 times heavier than the earth
shut up about the sun
shut up about the sun amy is going to be
very angry maybe even angrier than when
they added yolo to the dictionary you
know i wouldn't worry about it amy's
like
physically incapable of being mad at you
i don't think she'll be disrespectful
but
certainly she'll be upset watch this
amy someone lost your pen girl gina
you better be joking that pen is my best
friend and i will straighten captain
holt oh that's fine it's just a pen
it's just a pen i failed you santiago
i want my officers to respect the chain
of command but i never want anyone to be
so terrified of me that they repress
basic emotions i'm a terrible captain
stop that
you are not a terrible captain santiago
face facts i'm garbage
no this is about me and my issues with
authority you've been great
wrong i've been a disaster i can't
believe you would blame yourself for
this how stupid are you so stupid i'm
such a stupid head
the fact that you think this has
anything to do with you is insane do you
even
oh my god i'm yelling at you yes you are
you're in the zone keep going oh okay
i can't believe you lost my pen that was
careless and rude
and and it was a real jerk move santiago
you did it and i am so sick of you
playing your damn classical music in
your office all day
it's too loud we can all hear it okay
well this is
you shut your mouth when i'm talking to
you santiago right too far
i'm sorry this is all very new for me
[Music]
okay who put my calculator in jello
good one but uh seriously
guys who did this
seriously guys who did this
i need to know who put my calculator in
jello
or i'm gonna lose my freaking mind
do you remember rosa's reaction last
time the printer jammed
i'll pay for that you want me to be
happy
of course part of the problem is
she is the mother of a close friend of
mine
oh more than a friend a co-worker
oh gossip who is it
who is it
who is it michael
oh it's okay
no no no no no
oh my god oh my god
[Music]
that could have gone one of two ways but
i never expected her to get upset
okay i got your favorite cake
blue i'm not hungry it's a figure of
speech obviously i'll have some
and i have a mission to accomplish make
sure this party gets rolling and i will
be back shortly ew
where are you going you want me to come
with oh he says listen i forgot to tell
you the plan for this saturday
you me bar beers buzzed
wings shots drunk waitresses hot
football cornell hofstra slaughter
then quick nap at my place and we hit
the t sound no
i don't want to do any of that duh
which is why i was joking about doing it
just stop stop
just stop doing it you're going to drive
me crazy
fine i'll just go sit at my desk and be
quiet sorry i annoyed you with my
[Music]
friendship
and i'm also sorry that a lot of people
here
for some reason think it's funny to
steal someone's personal property and
hide it from them
here's a little news flash it's not
funny in fact it's pretty freaking
unfunny
you